Biden McCarthy reached that ceiling deal
to avoid default and here's what's in it
President Joe Biden and house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy have reached a debt
ceiling that are June 5th deadline Biden
described the bill as a compromise where
no one got everything they wanted the 99
page agreement includes Provisions to
keep non-defense
spending stable in 2024 fiscal year and
increase it by one percent the following
year it also included a two-year debt
limit increase the deal fully funds
Medicare for veterans including 20.3
billion dollar fund for toxic exposure
and expense work requirements for the uh
for the super supplemental nutrition
assistance program snap and snaps with
changes expiring in 2030
the agreement resents around 30 billion
dollars in unspent coronavirus relief
money while exempting funding for
Veterans Medical Care housing assistant
Indian Health Service and a program for
covid-19 vaccines it introduces changes
to the National Environmental Policy Act
to streamline the process Additionally
the deal ends the pause on student debt
loan repayment within 60 days although
the gop's proposal to rescind the White
House plan to waive student loan that
did not make it into the package the
house is set to vote on the legislation
on Monday so here are six things you
must know from the new debt ceiling from
political number one work requirements
the deal tightens work requirements for
snap and temporary system for needy
families and it introduces new time
limits uh for uh receiving food
assistance affecting individuals up to
54. number two energy permitting the
deal permits mining changes to the
permitting process for energy projects
clean energy funding totaling hundreds
of billions of dollars cover that
clawbacks IRS Cuts what's the IRS cuts
the deal Clause back a portion of the 80
billion dollars in funding to the IRS
the exact amount is not spending
specified but it's relatively small
compared to the Republican demands which
is sought to rescind over 70 billion
dollars snap at spending caps uh they
went from non-defense uh largely flat at
around 637 billion dollars so in other
words the left one and got what they
wanted that's what the negotiation
sounds like defense funding is captured
right at the president 86 student loans
the deal preserves President Biden's
plan to cancel student debt up to twenty
thousand dollars the agreement allows
the education department to resume
collecting monthly student loan payments
and interest potentially costing around
eight five million dollars each month so
Tom when you see this here who won this
negotiation uh Democrats did there is no
strong enduring change that's going in
here remember the IRS all those new
agents and all the regulations are going
to go out and do all this and turn the
IRS into a sort of a militarized that
guess what that 80 billion dollars is
still intact the thing I read said that
maybe 10 billion dollars was trimmed off
of it remember that 80 billion was new
remember all those agents that they were
going to hire and everything that's all
in there so okay take 10 billion off
that but the rest of it's funded and
then you look at the student loans
um student loans okay you're still going
to 20 000 off the top so the American
taxpayer covers that for everybody that
studied art history or uh you know one
other useless degree feminist Theory
yeah yeah exactly exactly sitting on
debt all the rest of us are going to to
take care of them for twenty thousand
dollars and but they can go back to
trying to collect the um uh the balances
from everybody else and the other
partner that I I notice check this out
the work requirements and the needy
assistant they expanded and then but
they Sunset the limits in 2030. what's
20 30. that's two presidential elections
and a midterm away
so there is an intentionality to Kick
the Can on providing entitlement here's
what the Republicans got they got out of
it saying hey we want to reduce all this
dependency money we want to reduce this
entitlement money we want work
requirements so that we do don't
basically it becomes Universal basic
income if you're just giving it to
people and there's no requirement to
work you follow that Pat it basically
becomes Universal basic income except
all of a sudden you go back and this is
going to expire in 2030. so the
Republicans put an expiration in there
you know what the expiration is two
presidential elections from now it all
goes back to
yeah to free money and the the energy
permitting yeah you know minimal changes
the permitting process for energy
project which means it's not allowing
Drilling and expansion of um Shale oil
or other things like that but clean
energy gets its billions which is gonna
head right for the Auto industry at 7
500 bucks a car if you buy a green car
but just don't try to plug it in
California because when all those people
in California have
electric cars you're going to cause so
in other words Biden is a better
negotiator than McCarthy
yeah yeah somebody got up to the I don't
know if it's Biden is a better
negotiator or there was just more
imagine if you're McCarthy you're in
your 40s 50s you're young for the rest
of your life your legacy is going to say
you couldn't negotiate with an 82 year
old yeah what a freaking great legacy
great job that was 58 years old got out
negotiated by 24 year old older man who
uh has a hard time going up the stairs
Falls three times but he beats you and
then by the way while you control
Congress yeah while you control it's not
like you didn't have Congress you have
Congress and you were House of represent
and you wouldn't drive it harder to get
what you wanted there's a lot of people
on his camp that are not happy with
their negotiation so the only thing
that's good about this is 30 billion
dollars which was effing pork that was
sitting off to be used for any purpose
whatsoever that was part of the
coronavirus relief that was 30 billion
dollars that the Dems are put in there
to use for anything that got ax that was
a it's called an earmark it was a big
ear Mark and that got pulled out but um
you look at everything that's in here
this is such an opportunity to do things
for the country and they kicked the can
down the road and they gave in on a
bunch of things and
they put a 20 30 deadline and going back
to the American public basically giving
Ubi to a lot of people that are
perfectly able to work and just don't
want to and Biden's going to spend this
obviously Biden's one gonna spin this I
would absolutely of course I mean I mean
spin as in what to say hey we look what
we did yeah of course yeah of course
agreed but by the way I mean If This
Were A Movie if we we've seen the debt
ceiling thing happen year after year you
know every handful of years this is a
freaking Marvel movie like Tom talks
about it's like the world's coming to an
end we need someone to save us the debt
ceiling's crashing down oh Marvel did it
again thanks Captain America thanks
Superman thanks Batman we all know how
this was going to end thank god
um but it's not like this was gonna they
were gonna let this happen yeah and I
mean I'm not surprised I mean a former
government employee here like the
government operates in what I call
Controlled Chaos you know continuing
resolutions raising the debt ceiling all
the time I think we've done it like 100
times or something like that it's like
World War II so they're always operating
under okay let's just get this let's
make it to this point and then just
increase it down the road exactly it's
literally quintessential kicking the can
down exactly but at some point
that Road's gonna have to come to an end
the government shutdown got recycled
homie you know yeah you know the
government shutdowns all that stuff I've
been through several government
shutdowns when I was a an agent and it's
just you know and then here's the thing
you're considered an essential employee
when you're law enforcement yeah so you
know you would still go to work and like
all right I guess I'll get paid an Alum
sum in like a month from now it just
kind of that paycheck's coming just yeah
it comes just not now whenever you have
a government it happened under Trump I
want to say where they yeah they hold
the negotiation with Pelosi and Schumer
and she's like yeah everyone's gonna
blame him
don't worry I'll take it and then but
what we saw happen is you know 67 of
this country lives paycheck to paycheck
yeah including government employees for
sure so when they don't get their check
in two weeks or in a month oh I remember
the crowd gets Restless the last
government shutdown
um that that went down when I was an
agent like everybody was freaking out
man like oh man what's gonna happen blah
blah blah this is you know pre-pandemic
but yeah every time it happens I want to
say yeah yeah like yep under under Trump
so luckily it didn't last as long as
when it was under Obama but it happens
you know that's what it is the
government is perpetually kicking the
can down the road so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]